- D'emblée, le procureur général
annonce qu'il va rendre publique
de perquisition.
"Mon département vient tout
juste de déposer une requête,
dit-il,
... pour rlelelelelelelelelelele
de la perquisition." Selon lui,
l'affaire est d'intérêt publique
à cause de Donald Trump.
"Donald Trump est inquiet
parce qu'il sait ce qu'il y a
dans les boites, dit son ancien
et piégé."
C'est lundi matin, vers 9 h,
que des agents du FBI se sont
rendus à la résidence de
l'exrérésident avec un mandat
de perquisition. Ils auraient
récupéré une douzaine de boîtes
secrets, censés aller
auaux archives nationales.
Depuis, le camp Trump parle
d'abus de pouvoir,ititititititi.
En plus du juge fédéral qui ag,
le FBI a été la cible d'attaques
sur les réseaux sociaux.
Aujourd'hui un homme armé a
même tenté de pénétrer dans
les bureaux du FBI à Cincinnati,
en Ohio. Après un état de siège
de plusieurs heures, l'homme a
"Je ne vais pas garder
qu'on attaque l'intégrité
de nos agents, qui sont
des patriotequququququququququqé
des Américains."
Ici, les spéculatn,n,n,n,n,n,nt
que ce serait un proche
de Donald Trump qui aurait
alerté le ministère deeeeeeeeeee
l'ancien président détenait
toujours des dossiers qui
pourraient porter atteinte
CeCeCeCeCeCeCeCeCeCeCeCeCeCeCeCe
proche du président, dit-il,
"... une personne qui a vu
les documents et qui savait
où ils
Le Washington Post vient de
révéler que les agents du FBI
recherchaient des documents
portant sur l'arcocococococococn
pour rendre publique le mandat
de perquisition et Donald Trump
pourrait s'y opposer.
Ici Azeb  R R R R R R R R R R o